it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases necropolis is a
third-person rogue light dungeon crawler
with permadeath you craft equip and
explore and fight to stay alive as you
delve deeper and face even greater
threats but if you're afraid to go alone
take a buddy there's up to four player
online co-op with the ability to drop in
and drop out pretty easily that way if
you fall your friend can pick you back
up but friendly fire is on so they can
also knock you down I guess well play
with people you like you start dungeon
diving on the 12th the Ghostbusters
franchise has had a long run of video
games associated with it you've probably
played one of the games for better or
for worse the new one is based off of
the most recent reboot so yes you're
playing one of the four new characters
with three of your friends in couch
co-op capturing spectres around New York
City each character will have their own
personality their own strengths and
their own play style this is encouraging
you to come up with strategies together
to take down those ghoulish fiends say
hi to slimer on the 12th song of the
deep is an upcoming Metroidvania style
game from insomniac you might not have
heard of it you're a young girl crafting
a makeshift submarine in search for your
father who went missing while fishing
you explore a vast ocean finding
upgrades for your sub and that keeps you
moving forward a bit of combat and some
puzzle solving helps mix up pace but if
nothing else you'll enjoy exploring the
beautiful vast open waters in this
light-hearted and thought-provoking game
you go into the blue on the 12th
3ds owners get another reason to make a
new set of armor in Monster Hunter
generations it's the same team
exploration and monster hunting you've
come to expect from monster hunter but
generations has some really smart
crossovers like this okami outfit and
toon link for the in-game cats you can
inhabit and play as but there's more
Monster Hunter generations introduces
all new gameplay mechanics including
hunting styles and Hunter arts to
customize your play style there's a lot
more giant beasts to take on so eat a
good meal and get back out there hunter
your quest starts on the 15th finally if
you're more of a minimalist perhaps
video ball will catch your eye at a
glance this looks more of a soccer air
hockey thing where you're putting a ball
into the other team's goal but there's a
bit more than meets the eye you can
shoot projectiles at the ball but also
at the opposing team as well as make
defensive barriers to mix it up is game
supports up to 6 players in online or
local multiplayer or AI if you just want
to practice alone it's a simple game but
the competition's fierce so if you want
to try a new party game this might be up
your alley and that's it for this week
do you remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings sometimes
they change I'll see you again next week